the world is apprehensible only through  examination and introspection and  through the Transcendence of egoism that  each human is endowed with he goes the  enemy an enemy that can be confronted  only through self-awareness empathy and  knowledge the curse that has befallen  our species is that we cannot really  free ourselves from the will the will  can be released or negated but it can't  change within this landscape we ought to  attempt to operate in the most effective  way possible it sounds like an arduous  challenge it feels like a groping and  fumbling in the dark but schopenhauer  believes that the denial of the will to  live might be the only way to Salvation  from suffering this pessimistic Outlook  towards life is observed all over his  narrative and it was because of the  stone that many refer to him as the  philosopher of pessimism